a cinco días de la ceremonia inaugural
los juegos olímpicos de tokio se ven
amenazados por el creciente número de
casos positivos de kobe 19 entre los
competidores después de que se
confirmaran tres casos positivos en el
mismo equipo de la villa olímpica los
organizadores dicen que están trabajando
al máximo para limitar el número de
casos en el evento
queremos ser unos participantes
realmente impecables en los juegos y eso
es algo que transmitimos constantemente
y lo hacemos para lograr estos objetivos
unos juegos seguros para los
participantes y unos juegos seguros para
la población japonesa
seyed game for happiness is good
vibrations los competidores detectados
fueron retirados de la villa donde
permanecerán miles de atletas y
trabajadores durante los juegos más
controvertidos por celebrarse en medio
de una pandemia
el riesgo cero no existe y todos estamos
de acuerdo al mismo tiempo la mezcla y
el cruce de la población son
increíblemente limitados increíblemente
limitados incredibly limited
y podemos asegurar que la transmisión
entre los distintos grupos es casi
imposible
estrés alto casi wifi almost este
anuncio se produce al mismo tiempo que
las autoridades locales japonesas
informan de que las cifras de contagio
en la capital registraron su mayor
número de contagios diarios de kobe 19
en los últimos seis meses superando los
mil casos durante cuatro días
consecutivos